hi good afternoon and welcome to our
interview with the Japan Co team also
known as the Google Play Developer
console preview teen today we're joining
our lovely hang out little room here
with Ricardo and Max and Ellie yeah yeah
you're good known as I and of course
we're here to discuss the brand new
Google Play Developer console preview
which hopefully you've had a good chance
to to try out see the new features
really awesome new UI um I'll leave you
in the capable hands of max I think to
start with who's going to run through
some demos for us I want the new
features yeah so really quickly before
we jump into demos I guess wanted to
just make sure you all know why we built
the new developer console big reasons
we've gotten from it was you know you
guys are using the developer console
more and more to update your
applications you're really growing your
businesses and we had a bunch of
features we want to be able to add in
the future and we wanted to give you a
great user experience so that was the
motivation for doing it and so this year
at Google i/o we announced and demoed
the new developer console and then last
week you all got access as Richard
mentioned so we wanted to say that what
we have here is a preview it's not
totally done yet I'm sure many of you of
you know found things that you'd like to
see improved before we consider it done
and a couple features we haven't
released yet but we also hope that
you'll see this is kind of a foundation
in a platform for more things to come so
we really welcome all of your feedback
about how we can continue to improve it
so max is going to walk us through what
we have in the preview today cool um
which is my screen and we make my screen
visible for everyone of course we get
the effect here we go you may remember
the demo at the google i/o ah so you may
remember this f so basically that's the
the start page of you if you arrive on
the on the new page and you see how the
the honey handy developer guide
which got published during the Deen wet
at Google i/o so yeah you start with the
store listing with the most important
information about your app well
interesting is with a new page we now
support up to 49 m localized information
so for instance um let's try to add some
German to that app we still call it the
Handy developer guide and you know you
can add a description and so on and so
forth um we can save and publish try we
guess we should get an error for that
you see we also try to give you way
better information if you do something
wrong what did you wrong what you should
do to fix that um but let's see um let's
fix it what is the ok it's not very
interesting at this one of the other
things that you'll notice like Mitch max
mentioned is you have up to 49 languages
which is a lot more than we had before
we have some languages like UK English
and Turkish that we didn't have before
and another thing that you also notice
it's kind of an invisible feature for
listings where you don't provide a
manual translation or human translation
will create an automated translation
using google translate behind the scenes
and then users who are encountering your
store listing if it's not in their
native language once you've saved in the
new developer console they'll actually
see a button allowing them to view an
automated translation so just to be
clear you know the automated
translations are generated by google
translate and so they're obviously not
going to be as good as having a native
speaker of german like max from creating
the translation but until such time as
you're able to
you know get the services of a
professional translator they certainly
will go a long way and you don't have to
do anything to make the automated
translations happen once you've saved
your app the new developer console
they'll happen behind the scenes and you
can go ahead and update the default
language as often as you want and the
automated translates translations will
update automatically this is a change
from the old developer console word you
used to have to select a manual or an
automated translation for each language
where you wanted one and then you would
have it they didn't update properly so
here it all happens behind the scenes as
soon as you've saved your app in the new
console we've seen usually German is too
long so you leave it in the original
title um ok ah we save these changes
let's let's have a look into the other I
have to click that obviously and you get
a little running Android yeah the
running Android is one the best is
really best parts of the new app I think
that was the most popular feature with
our developer relations we love it some
kind of progress is always nice room
yeah oh no Meah and it's just cute I
think it's cute so um yeah the list of
countries where you cannot publish your
app obviously if you have a paid app you
see and can set the prices here sap has
no inner products let's look into the
APK screen um again we try to give you
as much as information as we can give
you on that page you see like the
supported devices I think this is a
great way to to go to a through your
through the devices to see what is where
your app is working on or we're not or
if you even want to exclude devices
because you know they're certain and
sets which you have where you have
problems you can add that here as well
and obviously if you have you have an
update um you can upload new apk here
and you see the changes so for instance
we have now localized information for
German in the app arm which gives you
know sometimes you may have like it's
it's I think also pretty good here
because you may
you know unfortunate the wrong APK to
upload or something like that and you
get immediately like the information
what changed so um yeah we want to just
give you as much as information as we
can give you to prevent any mistakes
from your side let's have a look into
statistics um same statistics we will
see some more on a different tab soon we
have all of these different dimensions
if you ever in doubt what it exactly
means there's the handy tool tip to give
you details about the differences
between active and total devices and
users I think once you get used to them
you know what it means and it's just
again like great you know we want to
give you can't just repeat myself as
much as information and we will let the
decision for you for you to what you
actually want it how you want to use it
um the new crashes overview is also
pretty cool um yeah we already owe any
time so um have a bunch of filters and
you can go through the stack traces and
you also might not that visible and last
reported here on that part you can see
the mouse pointer we also jump through
the details of everything yes this is
when I forgot that grid layout didn't
exist in older versions have been lesson
for me I'm and and as well they use a
messages to yeah what the you know
hopefully they will give useful
information like how how it exactly
happened um let's jump into one of
rich's apps um where we have pretty cool
ratings is it's an awesome app obviously
I ultimate stopwatch yeah and yeah
there's a new dimension which we just
recently added Ricardo maybe you can say
a bit more about that yeah we use it to
display basically all your ratings have
evolved over time because often that's a
interesting method to keep track
of the matter if measured developers
sorry user satisfaction and we offer you
basically two new metrics one is the
cumulative average rating and it tells
you basically their average over all the
ratings that your application has
gathered over time and these is exactly
what you see also in the storefront on
plato google com of the actual rating
that the developed the user Afghans
giveth given you and so basically the
last point in the chart that says that
we have a rating of 4.35 should match
what you see on the storefront about the
rating with rap currently has the extra
information that you get here in
addition today's the river time of this
rating is the breakdown by all the usual
dimensions that you already used to from
the other metrics that we offer so for
example you could see by I don't know
how the rating is / device and you can
see maybe that some devices get a user's
from the given devices give you a lower
rating than other users and maybe this
is indicative that you have not optimize
your application for a given device
maybe it uses different screen size and
you have not really optimized for that
so they divert the user experiences less
optimal by language as well maybe you
have now optimize your application for a
given language if not localized or user
rated poorly and another interesting one
is by application version because you
can see by rolling out a new version
whether you know people like it more or
not and maybe your old new version is
not as good as you thought and you want
to do some fixes and change the game if
the cumulative average rating over time
is provides out to abroad metric because
it accumulates all the rating even from
past versions even from reviews you know
if you have been out for a long time
previous months previous years then you
can switch to the daily average rating
which is exactly the same metric but
aggregated over a daily basis and these
gives you a much more granular
information about on each day users are
rating your your application and again
if you have depending on how many users
you have you may have very strong arity
of information that use you on a
particular day what is the average
that your application got and this gives
you a much more detailed information for
example when you want the closely track
our new launch is happening on you lunch
is going and as usual you can always
export this metric just like all the
others so if you want to do your own
custom aggregations on your on your side
maybe by merging together other data
sources you can get a full breakdown in
CSV format as well so you can proceed
from that absolutely excellent I didn't
know the ratings trending existed inside
their reporting is that being the stunts
since the news that's when I know this
was actually launched with last Monday
with a new developer console preview so
well I'm truly Maggie's event I'm
working on an update salesman stop
watching ok cuz I'll get to see the
training up his Maria I was noticing on
your stats actually that um for your
latest version that had an actually
better user rating than the other
versions i'm not sure if you knew that
but your update really wasn't updating
yeah i know you're working on tablet
support so you can see which devices are
rating at high-a the time so now like me
more go to see so you can't enjoy myself
as losers are enjoying that's brilliant
and in this case you may should work on
localization for portuguese but are not
very happy well then you just do that
for me they're just pressed I don't know
when I'll be with German you know they
won't somatic translation hello yeah
these relations are just with store
listing that's right actually for the
application oh yeah doesn't really have
any Street well yeah maybe Portuguese
these are just just more unhappy than
she's talking about writing in videos
actually forgot to show that page as
well to give you an overview about the
ratings um but as we just encountered
the you know the braid overview and the
details on the on the statistics page
and inner products and are also part of
them of the developer console some of
you had early access but that's now as
well life so um if you want to add a new
product um
it's Type O want to fix it because you
can't do it otherwise afterwards um
managed product and again it looks
pretty similar to the to the listing to
a store listing page for for your main
app um you know you don't want to
confuse you with too many different
widgets and so on so you can add all of
your information yes you're used to from
from your store listing obviously just
what is required for in a product and
you know easy just do the auto con word
you may want to check the detail prices
because guessing euro maybe 249 shots a
bit better but again want to give you
the tools so you can do everything
easily now we always try it it's
sometimes a bit difficult but we always
try we know they're like this some of
you developers are you know we have
full-time jobs and you love to develop
for android and do that on the side and
we try to support you in the same way as
we do it for big developers so um yeah
but as we said we're happy to get some
feedback today from all backgrounds of
developers so let us know if you have
any wishes of ideas and we're more than
happy to discuss that and yeah and maybe
even do it in the end um I think I think
I'm we have also the service and api's
here if you for instance use and good
job messaging you can configure that
here and I think that's basically from
us and I'm not sure Ricardo's anything
else well that's pretty much it yeah we
hope you'll give it a try and one other
thing to point out if you haven't
noticed it is the gigantic orange link
let's say give us me back in the upper
right hand corner we read all that
feedback personally and although we're
not able to respond to every message
that we did we do keep it all in mind
when we're planning future updates so
please click on it let us know what you
think and tell your friends thank you
very much Oh excellent yeah some good
stats and
learn something it's also parameter is
the trending ratings the only d cystic
is there anything else I would have
missed ah no those are those are the new
ones that we launched with the open
preview so we definitely see that as a
great way to identify opportunities to
improve your app and to also see every
time you release a new version did it
actually improve what your users think
about you hopefully it does thank you
that's always the doctor else are you
just going on sir oh yeah yeah I leave
it on me we want to switch back but okay
hello everybody so we have some
questions in the moderator but if you're
thinking of joining the Hangout and
asking the team something live there's a
good time to jump in and we'll get you
lined up to ask the questions also you
can comment on the G+ post for this will
be reading those as well so do you have
something from the moderator yeah I can
dive into the moderator questions ah
will it be put well before we go into
the questions I think it's best to
reiterate as we always say on our
developer and hangouts that we're going
to be talking we're not going to be
making any product announcement today
we're going to be discussing your
comments and feedback but any questions
of when we'll explore when will I get
feature why that we're not going to be
able to talk about afraid so I think the
best way to direct the conversation is
to give us like constructive feedback of
what you like and what you would like to
see more often the team but you know
asking for launch dates not so much so
with that in mind when will be possible
to moderate comments on applications is
I guess one of these forward-looking
statements we're not going to get into
that what we said well I guess what we
can say so far is it you know we we
realized that this was a really
important feature for developers so
we've wanted to get it out there as soon
as possible oh we've definitely heard
very strong feedback from a lot of
developers who don't have access yet
they do want to have access so we hear
that you want to have the access but
we're still trying to make sure that the
feature is working exactly as it should
for developers and users over and you
know hopefully we'll be able to roll it
out more in the future but as Nick
mentioned we can't really make any
announcements in this meeting so the
next question is again asking for when
will accept them but I'm gonna rephrase
into feedback
great so Cheryl in France and asks he
says that these screenshots and feature
promo graphics that moment come out
slightly blurry due to compression and
so I'm going to freeze that too are we
aware of this and there are we looking
into this yes we are so we're aware of
that in the process in some cases the
spirit maybe God may be resized in the
way so we compress it on our end to save
space yeah we do we do some
optimizations for serving as well answer
yes we're aware of that so watch this
space essentially okay we've got someone
joined us in hangar just one small thing
you said that you he posted on the
YouTube channel to go to the link in the
description there is no link in the
description I was trying to put
something in the moderator but I don't
have a link in the description
apparently t try hitting refresh i I
have a close the page and reloaded it
still mopping alright let me take a look
at all try to fix every we've got a tan
pham engineer extraordinaire from the
mountain view office as kindly dialed in
lied i'm seeing a slice of here in the
bottom corner side when we can get that
sorted out for you pretty instantly next
question for moderator or n and israel
asks how can i delete or hide and
unpublished in that app well that is
something that has gotten nearly as many
requests as being able to reply to
reviews i think it's something that
we're you know looking into nothing to
announce at this point but thanks for
that feedback we've definitely heard
from developers that they want a way to
kind of declutter their interface some
people only have one or two apps and
they don't have this problem but some
people have all sorts of apps and at
some point they decide that they don't
want to maintain that app anymore or
they've created it by accident they'd
like to remove it so yeah thanks for
that feedback what right in thinking you
can delete an app it's never being
published not in the new site it hasn't
been implemented yet like i said totally
not finished yet this is one of things
we have it so the thing to do is be to
create a second android developer
console account and then using our
transfer the transfer
I would sorry it's a bit cluttered yeah
it'll sort itself out um yeah I'd like
this please I said the next question so
nicolet in Tokyo what he's asking will
gather any plans to publish an API fab
statistics so I guess we're not going to
kind of comment on future plans and so
on but I guess we're good for you then
to feed bang that he would love to see
some statistics API so I guess that
would be nice for automating your own
reporting mechanism so yeah definitely i
guess in the meantime you can use the
csv export them thanks for that people
yeah so we have a feeling affect more
than it's already many times yeah yeah
CSP is obviously yeah it's not as
powerful as an API but is the easiest
form to get access to this data and it's
a bit hard to discover books ESB also
include more complete profound and the
other metrics solid-phase interface you
see all ended up there but if you get to
CSP for example to get the full list of
devices if you're looking at device they
mentioned and so you can do more
complete analysis for using that so you
have any life gang going into that CSV
if you haven't tried it yet but we
rather than just relying their top ten
brothers were requested more complete of
yours cool and next request is that
obviously user X is loving the new dev
console so much he wants it to stick the
choice to be sticky rather than having
to opt in every time sort of the work
when he switched to try the new dev
console says he has to check it every
time yes that's correct as I was dig yet
not stay but uh just we're recording a
bookmark to the new one I think as you
can that is because a V ceiling issue
for URL so there ya can just judge about
it for now changeable box okay also
Aaron about a moving deleting apps from
your account I just had an idea that you
could just rename the apps that you
don't like to Zed so it's that and they
will just go down to the bottom of the
list I've just been into my accounts and
renamed the apps that I didn't want to
see that and they've all gone straight
to the bottom of the metal tilde resume
Nixon yeah so at least you don't have to
look at many more even if they're just
at the bottom of the page normal that's
a good idea does the new console have a
limit to the number of apps at appear on
the front page for ages 50 per page 50
per page
so it's more we did a diffused emissions
from the average number of application
that seems to be a good compromise
between the different if you say so
driving people in that paging yeah most
of time get everything in one page
before it was in 08 applications for
paging it was just not yeah okay uh
someone else's join us in the Hangout it
is so L so don't you have any questions
for the design of consulting hello hello
you're very quiet hello hello hello I
like listen yep you a hey Scott yeah
like listen regarding Android hello hi
please go ahead and ask the question oh
yeah I want to know that the half-life
is a secure using Android absolutely how
secure is it cheese and read it okay so
I don't think that's really a question
for the Android publisher site can you
perhaps come back into our office hours
we have on wednesdays at and 2 p.m. gmt
and ask the questions there we're going
to focus on the developer console for
this session ok ok ok thank you sorry ok
back into the moderator and so there's a
feature request here that they're
actually in London would like to see us
order comments on devices and by those
comments left by people on the same
device so feedback i guess for the
Google Play client do rather than
forever consult sorry what was it was it
being able to they'd like to see
comments from Wendy looking at
application on the buy-sell agreement
they still to see comments I waited but
I will rent biases of the same device
essentially she's a force and isn't that
later already in the web in the a Berber
client you can see you can see what
device it came from from my device
because there was a filter yeah it's
it's hard to find but I think it does
exist maybe
if your web version you're saying all I
know for sure to concern when you know
any rising surrounded a refuse from my
device or something it's not the
devaluation not social what's new if the
cookin reviews first see all reviews
most helpful first highest rating newest
options from my device model only so
whoever asks the question Ashley in
London Ashley in London of the do as an
option are you gonna be able to see this
it's on the right hand side of the
ratings and you can press it and choose
from my device my family excellent isn't
it next question Andy in brooklyn in USA
i asks you paying an api to facilitate
automated or at least more streamlined
published in updating so i guess you
can't say are we going to do are we
going to launch or whatever but is it
see that you've had is it something
definitely duration you're interested in
i think you know for developers who have
larger numbers of applications it's some
of them are definitely the cost of this
my problem with such things is I can see
people using it to publish to multiple
places at once in which case you get to
the lowest common denominator approach
whether or not take advantage of things
like this trick translation and so on so
forth forever storefronts might offer
saying I may be able full depending if
you have customized build tools or
workflows at which point publishes just
at the end of your chain but yeah there
is the third mobilization quite an
interesting comment from Daniel Baines
on the Jeep last post yeah one that I
haven't thought about before but may not
be too tricky it's about promoting your
applications at the level we give people
access to the Google Play branding and
the little button so they can read it in
their website he's asking for an
embeddable widget that you can put in
his website or a twist his applications
on the way store in a nice format with
the ratings that they have and just let
people click straight through and buy
them oh thanks for that idea Thank You
Daniel that is cool oh well how do you
think to help remotely yeah click or
telebuzz you really have the badge
generators for individual apps the
moment don't we we don't have one for
the sub page as well cheering I call it
for all your action something unusual
best cool try traffic around
cyssero again in France asks there's
currently no way to prepare a full
release you can upload an apk but all of
the extra information description
screenshot et cetera are not part of a
release as a result APK and information
are currently made available
independently yes that make sense yeah
that is true for our so the moment after
you are published right then you add it
basically each part of the application
independently but until the moment to
publish there are free to modify and out
information is as soon as you gather
them so you can start by saying I'm
putting in the store listing or a
screenshot because that's what my
designer gave me first and one day the
case ready you can you can add that in
the second moment until the moment of
your first publishing time you're free
to assemble your application in bits and
pieces so I guess he's asking like for a
way to tie like the description
everything clear a particular release
rather than having are you definitely as
you know we've definitely had some
developers ask for that because they
want to be able to do exactly what he's
talking about kind of prepare everything
and then at one moment kind of release
it as a unit so we definitely heard that
basically what we are all ready for new
apps but as you say ones are published
then partially losing that ability of
you can editing on the fly and without
publishing but yeah I know when you
upload a new application it can take a
couple of hours to get applications
through two people to see it um if you
make content description changes at the
same time is uploading to the
description changes go live in a
different types of the APK or is it all
happen at the same time christian i
think they are faster the year this
there's our check there's a bit of
caching and optimizations involved in
the pipeline through which from the
moment you submit something to the woman
gets live and that's also something new
I'm not sure I can draw much neater I
can give it but it's there are there are
different it's their different piece of
information take before they go live
interesting um there's another request
here on the moderator so Lucas is that
Lucas rocker Lucas has joined us here as
well I do want to ask your question liar
I Lucas thanks for joining us hello Lina
but I thought it would be nicer to ask
personally agree please d uh so uh I
know there's something in google play
for tracking campaigns and also you can
know where you're like new installs are
coming from ah but that involves like
changes in the app and all and for indie
developers that don't like have a lot of
infrastructure that's kind of a you need
to send this with some server so it's
more work when you don't have time or
resources to do it so it would be really
nice if if there was some sort of like
super simple mechanism to track where
noone stalls are coming from it could be
all things like like just for a start
like tracking what keywords search work
keywords are triggering new installs
inside the client so either web or on
desktop or the thermal app on the
android device that's one mmm let's see
like maybe like which page open Google
Play to install the new app so that's
nice for if you have a landing page then
if you're triggering new installs from
there you have some sort of way to gauge
that so that's another one anyway just a
few ideas but having a simpler version
of tracking referers on Google Play
would be useful especially for people
who don't have a lot of infrastructure
and so this would be like something even
simpler than integrating google
analytics is that kind of what you're
looking for uh yes ish yeah the thing is
like so just my personal take on that
like I usually try to avoid adding
Google Analytics if I don't have a like
trolls very strong reason for doing that
like if I can have just a simple way to
track where people are finding the app
and installing it that's fine because
Google Analytics adds like like take
spend with and like a lot of data
connection costs involved for for users
so if I can avoid that I prefer to not
add that so okay so
it's just a maybe a simple mechanism to
track where the install came from like
and if you want to go further and adding
your own infrastructure for server-side
or even Google Analytics that's that's
another step yeah it's good at it for
those for those you don't know what
looks were plenty there is a method that
made for tracking solar first if you
google for Android in saw a fair you'll
find a way you can pass particular kind
of campaign IDs all the way through so
you can track the effectiveness but yeah
I agree there's some work to be done
there and maybe there's a better way to
automatically surface this stuff so
thanks for the feedback so next question
is Daniel in London you done you will it
be possible in the future for developer
page to show developer details and
perhaps even integrate with their
Google+ account so that's a good idea
thank you for the future suggestion and
they'll be quite cool because you at the
moment if you go to a developer's page
you just see the list of their
application so might be might be nice to
have some glove there so yeah cool
thanks for the rest got another one in
the G+ stream from Phillip lenson who
says he would like to be able to just
feedback like to be able to click on the
headers of the all applications section
to reorder the listings to go out with
the most downloads with the most money
much for those things okay thanks for
that thanks for any more water races
yeah the last one I'm saying any plans
for better support for proguard and to
easier like a read your stack traces
when they beep regarded for native
crashes yeah well no just proguard
ignore faster if you upload your map of
your map file for the APK so you can
decode the stack traces and hmm native
is another kettle of fish but oh yeah
thanks for the feedback I like we say
we're not going Condit is coming or not
but thank you for the request I think we
exhausted the M yeah we're great running
low on questions now so we'll wrap it up
quite a bit but if I dear that is just
joined us again has another question for
us please yeah
on the moderator but you say that that
one was the last one so mana and maybe
doesn't record my I wanted to ask if
there will be a way to reply to for
users not developers to reply like the
developers can reply I mean and when in
a nap there are there are many apps in
Google Play that the Creator at the
developer have sort of abandoned and
many people with questions there mm-hmm
I'm thanks so they asked question and
there's no way to reply for them though
even as a user reply to another user's
comment yeah because then you can see
for example adw.launcher it it seems
like the developer completely neglected
and there are ton of people with
question there and no one can answer
them soon about social support forum for
future so forgive it out yeah huh I
heard that we're close before that's not
just almost turns into a comments
threatens their yeah yeah just to for
example like you have replies comment
sir not sure that's an example you want
to emulate thank you for the tea bags
are you checking the YouTube comments on
you anything any good questions coming
through their first Easter me questions
but none of them are related I mean I
wanted to be first and if any of you are
wondering throughout this hangout why
mine and nick's heads are so much bigger
than everyone else's it's because
they're actually beamed in from another
studio and there's a green screen here
is dis shay proposing so it's just been
I didn't work in oh we just go um um
that's not exactly related if you don't
mind it's about the market at that play
but not the drink there's developers in
the market there was a way to download
more than one apps one app him since you
updated to play it downloads one of the
time so if your darling like a 1 gigabit
gigabyte it takes forever and the other
one don't download it till the first one
finished
it's interesting you hadn't noticed that
it switched over you mean before do you
know how many would download at the time
before was it just two at a time where
you think there are indefinitely you I
have like 50 update to do update all and
the old download at once and now it's
done serial Carol right yuh now they're
all done see really surely he'd say
instead of in parallel they were doing
it together sital simultaneously but
slower speed but in general overall it
was faster than just one at a time I
guess the problem with that is you end
up as I don't know what the actual
problem was but you can end up with five
apps finishing at the same time then
trying to install so the Installer still
has to stack them one after the other
because you can only be installed in one
up at a time but I didn't know that it
happened all right it used to be one of
the up points against iOS that I used to
use for people but now I was updated
yeah nobody's I go to sleep cuz now iOS
does have disability and android does
not so it's kind of annoying hmm well
you're gonna be limited by your download
done with probably anyway right it
doesn't move because I for example me I
have 100 megabits per second so if you
nothing's wrong i'm slow it down yeah
it's right on fire you study mommy
doesn't join you guys are going to give
us one gigabit sometime soon if you're
in Kansas yeah yeah okay the in Kansas
three clicks ooh yeah eventually we'll
reach worldwide I hope trip on home
alright well I'd like to thank the
Quebec Google Play Developer console
preview team for joining us from
wherever there so I don't know it in a
magical office somewhere and thank you
for all your questions will they'll see
you Wednesday 2 p.m. UK time 3 p.m. CET
for our office hours so join me and
Roman Nurik tomorrow for Android design
in action for talking that way your
Android design needs please to Android
design is very important for us thank
you very much thanks and bye hey thank
you